[موسيقى]
السمنه مرض العصر ولا ترتبط بمستوى دخل
الفرد بل تطال الجميع فما العلاج المنتظر
ثلاثه اطباء وباحث في الولايات المتحده
تقدموا بطلب دراسه ادراج ادويه مكافحه
السمنه ويشمل الطلب المكون الفعال في عقار
الذي ستنتهي قريبا حقوق استخدامه الحصري
ما سيسمح بانتاج انواع منه اقل تكلفه
[موسيقى]
ينظم الوزن من خلال اعطاء الاشارات للمخ
بالشبع والماده الفعاله بذلك العقار هي
هرمون
الذي تفرزه الامعاء بصوره طبيعيه بعد
تناول الوجبات لكنه طبيعيا يستمر لمده
دقيقتين فقط اما في الدواء يستمر بثلاثه
عشره ساعه
بعد موافقه منظمه الصحه العالميه والمنظمه
الاوروبيه للغذاء والدواء على ساكسيندا
بدات دور العلاج لكن بواسطه طبيه وفي حال
اعتماد القرار فسيفتح ذلك المجال لادخال
عقاقير السمنه تحت مظله التامين الصحي وهو
ما سيضمن جودتها والقضاء على عشوائيه
انتشار العقاقير المخالفه وبالتالي تقليل
نسبه الاصابه بالسمنه وامراضها لكن لا
يفضل ان يستخدمه المصبق المصابون بسرطان
الغده الدرقيه اولد عائلاتهم تاريخ مع
المرض لذا ينصح بعمل تحاليل قبل استخدام
الدواء